[Musique]
déjà la vie si tu quand est astucieux
bellemène
la jolie le plus sérieux à jouer vis de
vos doigts au prévenu azami
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ça brille ça bonjour
tout encore tu vas bien oui bonjour à
tous bonjour à tous j'espère que vous
êtes en pleine forme parce que tout cas
encore me semble frétillant ah ben oui
tu vas voir
oui préparer à un jeu là à on va voir si
tu es fort et tu sais si les dessins
info je me concentre oui faut que tu
paroisse sainte alors cédé 5 il faut
qu'il faut que tu reconnaisses l'ordre
dans le cahier une petite histoire tu
vois rien dessin numéro 1 au numéro 2 et
numéro 3 mais moi je ne vais pas te le
présenter comme ça ça peut être le 3 ans
1er tu joues tu vois ce que je veux dit
ah oui ça s'appelle l'ordre
chronologique
oui hein tu vois bon ça sera ça pourquoi
je vais remettre dans l'ordre quoi
l'affoler remettre dans l'autre il ya il
ya des indices bien précises alors voilà
par exemple aux dires de le premier la
regardes tu vois une cuisine tu vois oui
une jeune fille la wii elle épluche le
chat non non mais non jouée par amanda
laird et éplucher des pommes de terre il
ya un chat oui plus là il ya des choses
tu vois c'est une reprise d'une coiffe
pop star et moi c'est mon dessin or il
me faut un bon jeu les a fait d'ailleurs
ses dessins nom hervé legrand hervé
legrand
on a du talent on le bougre abbès je
crois alors maintenant tu vois même
situation c'est la même cuisine et ça
c'est la même cuisine c'est la mairie
qui vacille on sait la même jeune fille
les loyers et une tortue de ses amis ah
oui là il ya une visite des tortues des
tortues est toujours en train d'éplucher
des yeah et puis c'est la cuisine bord
tu as l'air perplexe samba jeunes gens
gardent tous les détails pour ne pas me
tromper tout à l'heure et bien tourner
ma tante seconde parlé trop vite sinon a
pas moi je vais pas trouver
voilà à
oui oui oui s'éclairer maintenant oui il
a maintenant il ya la jeune fille
toujours
et puis il n'ya plus il ya plus de shia
plus la tortue moi je crois que j'ai
trouvé
est ce que tu peux le mettre dans
l'ordre maintenant beaucoup de jeu de
faire une proposition
nous allons mettre en numéro 1
le dessin attends je trouve cela être
celui-là sur lequel il y a le moins
d'épluchures car moi ce qui m'a frappé
dans cette série de dessins c'est qu'il
y avait une suite logique dans les plus
chers des pommes de terre or si on
considère que cette jeune fille est en
train d'éplucher il normal de commencer
par le dessin et sur lequel il ya le
moins des peluches lui aurais tu ensuite
je mettrais si logique serait tout à
fait logique
je mettrai le dessin sur lequel il ya
déjà un certain nombre d'épluchures par
terre ce sera le second stade de ce
travail qu'enfin ce qui me paraît tout à
fait logique
le dernier dessin sur lequel il y a
alors beaucoup beaucoup d'épluchures par
terre je crois que là je gérais tabula
situation comme elle devait être malin
c'est ça la vie un 4e ou via des lego 10
et plus surnommés de sabre et j'ai dit
qu'on ne met pas sinon je trouve
pourquoi c'est celui-là tu as bien fait
tu as bien fait ou encore t'es bien
contente toi très bien non qu'est ce que
tu fais toi maintenant tu le sais pas où
en principe je sors et basse et ça n'est
pas sortant et moi je vais retrouver mes
amis
d'accord je me traîne jusqu'à vous
c'était pas si les éplucher alors
c'était facile
même moi je leur ai tous eus m'ont amri
on peut appeler fabrice vous et oui
allez on l'appelle tous ensemble fabrice
abriel et voilà j'arrive d'espoir pour
le jus du point commun à j'avais
d'ailleurs le rappeler si tu le veux
bien ce jeu du point commun à nos amis
simplement vous allez tous tous les
trois représentées soit un objet soit
une chose faite c est notre travail à
vous et à moi consiste à découvrir quel
est le point que vous avez en commun
oui parce que on va dire des choses
astucieuse abonnement commun
la série a commencé c'était tu me
pardonnes belle bella 8 a pris les
moines qui debise web à vide en moi je
vais te dire on m'aime beaucoup
quand même beaucoup et on ne connaît
depuis longtemps en france doit faire au
moins 300 ans d'ailleurs on m'a précis
tu sais quand banon le matin au réveil
on apprécie après le déjeuner tu sais
comment on meurt en bon m'approche on me
respirons mup hume on ne déguste
enfin bref je suis du café et alors je
viens de loin je viens du brésil de la
colombie de l'afrique et il en fait
subir des préparations me fait briller
on me réduit en poudre
on enlève la caféine voilà tu vois c'est
ça c'est ça tu es du café je suis dit tu
as fait très bien
tu as dit que moi je suis une
merveilleuse ça ne traîne pas fabrice et
le merveilleux est une merveilleuse
plage sur laquelle les enfants adorent
jouer et où les grands viennent
s'allonger pour se faire bronzer
tu sais une de ses immenses plages de
sable fin
doré comme la baule les sables d'olonne
tu sais quand j'étais petit parce que
j'étais petit avantage grotte et
j'allais souvent pour mes vacances sur
les plages aux jouets dans les bus dans
ces coucous et puis on construisait les
châteaux de sable et châteaux de sable
oui à la wii et pousse moussu
qu'est-ce que tu est aujourd'hui robin
moi moi je suis je suis un peu désolé
parce que je viens quelques fois troublé
ces enfants qui jouent sur le sable
justement les remarques jeunes et
troublent pas longtemps je ne fais que
passer
glissez un certain moment on voit un
petit nuage qui arrive alors il grossit
grossit
puis d'un seul coup hop y crève et en
quelques minutes on est trempés et puis
alors que le soleil vient et puis on
oublie très facilement en somme je ne je
ne suis qu'une petite pluie passagère
alors oui euh attendez attendez attendez
le café la plage m'en fallait insister
sur le sable alors je pense que c'est
dans cette direction qu'il faut aller et
puis tu m'as dit
qu'est ce qu'il me dit toi à bas le
petit nuage oui le petit nuage
le petit nuage la banque fruits ça me
paraît évident maintenant en y
réfléchissant bien le grain les affaires
le grain de sable
et puis un petit grain dans le temps
mais alors qui est le plus fort robin
c'est ce que je voulais bien bon la
prochaine fois on fera mieux d'ailleurs
moi je fais tout de suite faire mieux
fabrice jeu tête aux jeux musique
charles sika a tout de suite tu es prêt
j'espère que tu as fait des progrès et
enfin ben je me méfie parce que ici j'ai
appris quelque chose pour écrire il a
pris tout son matériel oui c'est bien
bon alors cette semaine alors c'est un
mot un mot ans il être que je vais
essayer de te faire deviner
oui ans il être sa créance par la
première 1 m
comme comme maurice oui 1 nm à et la
dernière alors la dernière 1 e
alors à quand tu m'as dit s'il est
repris alors tu fais de quatre petits
traits et 1 e 1 e
mais reste alors je t'écoute à paris tu
m'écoutes tu m'écoutes alors on
recommence
mais ça n'a ni mal et non non est ce une
fleur une quoi une fleur ah bah écoute
tu trouve vite alors oui c'est une fleur
c'est une valeur qui peut très très très
jolie une fleur jolie et est ce que
cette icône et que je te donne une
lettre à ce que leur mois les fleurs
c'est pas mon domaine oui mais parce que
moi j'en ai beaucoup autour de la
reprise est bien seul à l'être alors
attends c'est pas un g c'est la
troisième la troisième lettre est sûre
de toi ou je suis absolument sûr ça hein
j'ai que ça peut bien être
c'est une belle c'est une fleur qui et
rouges aux noms changent mais les
blanches fleurs blanches on est beaucoup
autour de moi très agréable c'est très
agréable
oui je me demande si tu vas pas me
coller aujourd'hui
une petite est ce que c'est une est-ce
que c'est une fleur sauvage leur nom et
le portement sauvages ont planché soit
elle n'a jamais fait mal à l'épaule
sauvageons nounou quels sont les petites
clochettes tu vois ce que je veux dit à
l'ats beaucoup des petites clochettes
comment veux tu que je n'imagine une
chose pareille tu ne penserait pas par
hasard au muguet mais s'ils battent à
trouver le budget mais comme muguet mais
moi muguet il me faut un thé à la fin de
muguet comment est ce que tu as écrit
muguet ben juger a et e
nuc et mon dieu plus guerrier on s'est
pris un coup de pouce moussu mais tu
fais n'importe quoi fin le muguet
comment veux tu que je découpe pour
l'intrigué muguet voyons un coup d'pouce
moussu mg et e t on un peu seul si tu
m'écris muguet comme ça je peux le
trouver nous laisse patauger à dix mois
du doigt l'algérie moi oui
un propos à propos de muguet est ce que
tu sais qu'il faut faire très très
attention
j'ai une façon de cueillir le muguet
avant lui une manière très spéciale se
faire très attention aux feuilles
oui les ans les petites clochettes là
que tu peux accueillir autant que tu
veux un elle se détache très facilement
mais si tu veux être certain d'avoir
encore beaucoup de muguet l'année
prochaine eh bien il faut faire
attention il faut pas cueillir toutes
les feuilles
oui c'est grâce à elle que l'ami
suivante tu pourra offrir de beaux
bouquets aux gens que tu aimes bien un
et tu sais ces gens là malheureusement
il n'y pense pas assez souvent
heureusement qu'ils se rattrapent un
toucan gambas
photo g je connais beaucoup de choses
moi dans la forêt c'est vrai dans ce
domaine tu connais très bien la forme
malheureusement l'orthographe
ah bah ça je dois dire qu évidemment ça
progresse pas trade mais j'essaierai de
faire mieux la prochaine fois on peut
toujours le croire le muguet pourrait
pousser sur pouces boussu après oui
certainement mais déjà des fleurs
s'oppose à ce que ça marche très bien
une belle jeu musical avec moi c'est
facile à musique de la famille à 5,2 me
samassa d'aurier à la famille façon dont
a mis seulement ça c'est la deuxième
bombe ben oui mais je suis heureuse de
t'avoir à moi nous allons commencer
notre jeu des notes de la gamme wii le
jeu des bonnes notes
oui nous allons jouer tous les deux nous
paraît à la marraine tu veux ensuite tu
veux oui alors nous allons imaginer que
nous avons une grande quantité de fioul
garçons et filles et nous allons les
baptisés à on le retrouve en bien sûr
des jolis prénoms d'accord tout informés
alors qu'ils voient bien la situation
il faut jouer avec les notes de la gamme
toujours le mcdo la gamme alors nous
avons donc imaginé que de nombreux
petits enfants nous sont arrivés et sont
arrivés comme ça un peu comme en alsace
peut être apportée par des blues boy a b
ab blood gogniat
on joue déjà oui à la demande 3d
bourgogne moi je dirais tient des six
pièces
je suis très bon alors apporté par des
sea dogs oui imaginons que le premier
soit un garçon est ce que tu es une idée
déjà pour un garçon de garçons robin
écoute un garçon moi j'en aurais bien
être proposées mais je ne sais pas si ça
va te plaire
écoute moi je commencerai tu vois un
prénom qui peuvent pas par ça voilà à
quoi est battu rocco la regarde je vois
pas du tout qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est un fait oui alors facois fabrice
par exemple
voilà à bastia dont tu as très très bien
compris bon allons maintenant on cherche
un prénom pour une fille fait virer
comme moi personnellement j'aime
beaucoup le prénom de nids
alors là immédiatement
sido ces données sidonie métro basile et
si on pourrait aussi l'appeler sido tout
court ce serait mignon aussi non tu
aimes pas céder alors encore avec deux
notes et masculin quelque chose avec
dunlop
oui aussi un prénom masculin up
immédiatement je te fais un prénom qui
est très joli os et oui celui là c'est à
dire celui là nick qui peut aller aussi
bien à une fille qu'un garçon technique
un baby boom ni de oui oui alors moi je
te propose celui là celui là ça nous
fait deux mini à qu'il est fort il ya
aussi des ddd blue blood des blues
mais voilà là c'était exprès je voulais
que tu sèches des idées seulement à ce
moment-là on dit doremi pas sur la vie
dont on sait difficile sa maman non
c'est trop difficile ça l agecale et
chante maintenant ta remarque est dans
les 4 z'a il ya quelque chose à la fin
me céda voilà on va le mettre pour
rejoindre vers l'iss voilà attention
hein
les cats a déjà île peuplée de la vie
majeur s'est désisté léger choc c'est
des choses mais comme je ne nie pas de
mine noir il faut pas fait attention les
califats n'y connaissant rien mais ça me
semble heureux car il aime la vie
oui
[Musique]
wie a joué aujourd'hui et vouloir
devenir un ami
e
[Musique]